hey this is sort of funny um donald
trump did a press briefing over the
weekend once again at his bedminster
golf club and much like last weekend
some of his supporters who were guests
at the club were allowed to go to the
briefing and it's another example of
trump generating these sort of
rally-like atmospheres with friendly
crowds
even though he's supposed to be
seriously briefing america and the press
about
that thing called the coronavirus
pandemic which killed 7
000 people in the last six days it's
sort of like a
rally uh atmosphere with his supporters
cheering in the background it's weird
but the crazy thing is that even the
friendly crowd
and the cheering couldn't make trump
look sensible
and he instantly fell apart even in
front of a friendly crowd
so let's look at some of the clips trump
started by talking about how
cases are going down despite testing
which
continues to expose that donald trump is
very very confused about how
testing relates to cases and by the way
there were fifty five thousand cases the
day before trump did this press briefing
listen to what donald trump had to say
nearly 85 percent
of jurisdictions all across our country
are reporting a very steep
decline in cases and that's despite the
fact that we have the number one testing
program anywhere in the world
we're up to almost 70 million tests far
beyond any other country
this week cases nationwide have declined
by six percent
so of course trump doesn't get it more
testing reduces cases over the long term
because people know they have it they
know they're contagious they stay home
that ship has sailed he's just not going
to understand that or he's refusing
he's at least pretending not to
understand that so then it starts to get
ugly very quickly
trump here suggests that the numbers on
the virus are so good
that he must win in other words how
could a president
who has such great numbers on the virus
not be re-elected that's where donald
trump's mind
is iran would love to have me defeated
if
if i win which i hope to win how can you
not when you see numbers like this both
on the
virus and on the economy i mean we
should win we should all be
uh keep this incredible thing going and
i built it once and i'll build it again
i've already
i think the hardest part is done in
terms of the economy and that's with or
without
additional funds remember that as a
country
we have the eighth most cases per capita
in the world
if you don't include tiny countries
which can throw off the data
the us has the sixth most cases per
capita in the world
in terms of deaths we have the 10th most
deaths per capita in the world
again if you exclude places like san
marino and andorra
because they have tiny populations where
the number where just a few deaths
per capita is very high if you exclude
those we are eighth worst
in the world in terms of per capita
deaths and trump says
how could you not re-elect the president
with numbers so good
and at the end there you might have
heard trump start to say
we're doing great with or without
stimulus money like trump seems to be
suggesting here that the second stimulus
which is being debated right now
it may not even be necessary things are
just fine
which just shows how disconnected he is
from reality
he's asked about that specifically and
here he says it we can do it or not do
the second stimulus either way is fine
for him i guess he means
listen to me listen to me my people are
doing very good and my people call me
they're in the office they call me they
call me when it's right
nobody knows the deal better than i do
when it's right
i'll meet but right now it's not right
they want a trillion dollars to bail out
badly run
states state they're democrat they're
all i mean they're democrat states
will something happen possibly but i
want to tell you the country is doing
very well right now we can live very
happily with it without it
but i'd like to do it because i want to
give money to the people
i like how trump says we can be happy
with or without another stimulus
record unemployment highest gdp drop
on record last quarter businesses
still not functioning fully schools
closed or going remote increasingly as
the virus spreads
but trump is fine with or without a
second stimulus good to know right i'm
glad he's fine with it either way
trump is then asked about polling which
doesn't look particularly good for him
and trump is just rambling about
there are lots of boaters people with
boats who like
trump and have trump flags on their
boats
rivers and oceans thousands and
thousands of boats
it's called boaters for trump boaters
for trump pence
there's signs all over some of the boats
have 10 flags on them they're incredible
they're thousands we did nothing to do
this
this is just generic it just happened
the thing is
that you know the white florida boat
owner demographic
isn't enough to win it for trump he may
have enough to win it that's important
but the boaters in the intercoastal are
not enough to win it for donald trump
and here again trump goes into the stuff
about mail and voting
saying we might not know the results of
the november election
not for days not for weeks not for
months we might not know it for years
we are going to have an election that
takes place
on a beautiful day november 3rd and
usually at the end of the evening they
say
donald trump has won the election donald
trump
is your new president whatever they say
you know what
you're not going to know this possibly
if you really did it right
for months or for years because these
ballots are all going to be lost
they're going to be gone and just take a
look at a smaller basis but
it's great tests we're doing tests i
mean these are
you could call them polls you could call
them tests
look at what's happening all over the
country where you have
universal mail wait a minute the ballots
are lost
there's fraud there's theft it's
it's happening all over the place now
we're going to do it with this whole
vast big section of the country
it's crazy think about how insanely
hyperbolic that is
all the ballots will be lost and we
won't know who won
for years consider how ridiculous that
is
on what planet would we not know the
election results for years and by the
way
does trump know that if that happens he
stops being president on january 20th
it's not clear that
someone has actually said that to donald
trump and of course realistically
if there are a lot of mail-in ballots
and they have to be
postmarked by election day could take a
few days to get
counted it might take a few days to have
the final results and if it's really
close we might not know who is going to
be president in january
until like november 8th that's not the
worst thing in the world
let's get it right in many countries you
don't know the results
at midnight we think that we should that
doesn't have to be the way it is
then trump is asked about birtherism 2.0
which is about kamala harris is kamala
really eligible to be president
trump has a chance to denounce it but he
does not
campaign will you say now that kamala
harris is eligible
to run and be vice president or
president based on
be born in oakland california so i have
nothing to do with that i read
something about it and i will say that
he is a
brilliant lawyer that i guess he wrote
an article about it so i know nothing
about it but it's not something that
bothers me
but sir when you do that it creates why
do you say that i just don't know about
it but it's not something that we will
be pursuing
let me put it differently let me be let
me put it differently don't tell me what
i know
let me put it differently let me put it
differently
to me it doesn't bother me at all
i don't know about it i read one quick
article
the lawyer happens to be a brilliant
lawyer as you probably know
he wrote an article saying there could
be a problem it's not something that i'm
going to be pursuing
is she eligible i just told you
i have not gone into it in great detail
if she's got a problem you would have
thought that she would have been vetted
you would have thought that she would
have been vetted by sleepy joe yeah go
ahead
he's like you know i don't know much
about this but the guy who wrote the
article questioning whether kamala can
be vp
because to bvp you have to be eligible
to be president that guy's brilliant
that guy's credentials are super
super good and and you'd think joe biden
would have vetted her but you know i
can't i don't know anything about that
birtherism 2.0 is building and
it's arguably going to continue building
if other strategies don't go well
here trump does what i call the sir
routine
the sir routine is
we have a name it's crazy that we have a
name the sir routine is when trump
retells a story of someone saying
something to him that is advantageous to
him
and he'll say you know they came to me
and they said sir
blah blah blah you can almost guarantee
it didn't happen the way trump claims it
happened when he does
the sir routine i want to say that
i want college football to come back
these are strong
healthy incredible people these are
people that
want to play football very badly a great
great talent
quarterback trevor lawrence called me on
two days ago spoke to him a couple of
times
they said sir i want to just tell you we
want it back we want to play and
he's an incredible quarterback as you
know from an incredible school
clemson and he's going to have a very
good future
in the nfl sir they told me they came to
me sir
sir please start college football okay
uh some quick ones here donald trump
still
continues to refer to the 1918 flu
pandemic
as happening in 1917. um do you agree
with dr
robert redfield who earlier this week
said if america doesn't follow
public health guidelines we can be in
store for one of the worst faults we've
ever faced from a public health
perspective
no i mean you can't compare it to 1917
that was
incredible i was that was the worst ever
by far that was you look at they lost
possibly 100 million people no i don't
agree with that but
weirdly trump says that some people call
his own secretary of defense mark yesper
as opposed to mark esper just like a
very weird moment
with your defense secretary mark esper
do you have confidence in his leadership
there
mark jesper did you call him jesper
oh okay some people call him yesterday
no i get along with him
i get along with him fine he's fine and
then here again
it's that raucous atmosphere that donald
trump loves even if it's supposed to be
a serious press briefing
he actually suggests that he might fire
his entire cabinet if he gets reelected
he then dissembles into rambling and
walks off the stage to the applause
of his club going mostly mask wearing
sycophants
as far as your cabinet goes do you think
you'll see more turnover in your cap
well i don't know i think for next year
i mean generally speaking a lot of times
i understand when
if we win a president will ask for the
resignation of everybody and then bring
back the people he wants that's happened
before steve
and i could see something like that
happening i think that makes sense no
i have a very good cabinet i mean with
few exceptions i wouldn't say i'm
thrilled with everybody frankly
but i have overall i think we have a
very good cabinet
i think this i will say this no
administration
none no administration first three and a
half years
has done anywhere near what we've done
300
we will have at the end of the first
term 300 maybe more
federal judges including court of
appeals two supreme court justices
nobody has done this if take a look at
take a look at what we've done
the biggest tax cuts in history biggest
regulation cuts in history rebuilt our
military
took care of our vets we have a 91
approval rating from the vets nobody's
ever had a 91
approval rating before we i guarded the
second amendment
they want to destroy the second
amendment take a look at kamala
they want to destroy the second
amendment and as you know joe is has no
control over anybody
he has no control over himself okay
thank you very much everybody
thank you
that's considered in 2020 among
trumpists
a coronavirus press briefing from the
president of the united states as if
it's a serious thing
the cheering is just too much i would
love to interview the people there
right after they're done cheering and
trump walks off
what made you cheer what what exactly
were you cheering for what did you hear
from the president that you liked so
much
that made you cheer as he walked off
stage and
i've said before even in friendlier and
friendlier settings
trump is on fox and friends a friendly
setting and it goes terribly i'll talk
about that later
trump is on hannity it's a it's his
friend
and even hannity can't make trump look
good
a press briefing at his own club with
his supporters cheering
and he still looks like he has
absolutely no idea what's going
what's going on there is no setting
friendly enough
that can make donald trump look good at
this point in time
we're going to have more coverage of
this on our instagram page
which is davidpakmanshow on instagram
you can also follow me on instagram at
david.pacman coming up next
so much more very busy day as the
democratic national convention gets
started tonight i will be streaming
starting at 8 45
pm eastern time if you are anything like
me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into a doctor's office
right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com
to take the free quiz see which doctor
is right for you i took their quiz they
matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video